everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today we're in tiebreakers
the 2016 will chose championship Magnus
Carlsen in Sergey karyakin they played
12 games and at the end of it they are
tied so we come to the tiebreakers it's
actually Magnus Carlson's birthday so
what better way for him to celebrate his
birthday and if he could actually win
the World Championship so the format's
if you are not familiar we start with
four games of rapid chess rabbit chess
we're going to be looking at 25 minutes
for each player and then they do get a
ten-second increment on each of their
moves and if after four games they are
still tied which is very reasonable with
these players then we go into more of a
blitz style where they get 5 minutes
each and then three seconds are going to
be added on if there's still a tie after
that round then we get into an
Armageddon session which if we need to
we'll explain that in another video as
well but in this video we're going to be
looking at the rapid portion we are not
going to be going over games one and two
mostly because they both ended in
drawers and they were pretty much the
same games we've seen before
as you'll kind of see even with game 3
which we're going to be starting to look
at right now it doesn't seem like their
preparation really in telled much
different for this rapid section than
they have been throughout the tournament
because you're seeing a lot of the same
opening so this game number 3 why it's
going to be played by sergei carter
yakkung Carlsen drew the black pieces
for game 1 which means he has white
pieces in games two and four so he will
get to close this out so even if he were
to lose this game he does get the white
pieces in game 4 but we're going to get
started with Sergei cardiac in in game 3
all tied up starts out with pawn to e4
pawn e5 Knight f3 knight c6 same as
we've seen for most of the tournament
Bishop to b5 and then getting into the
the Morphy defense pawn to a6 Bishop
back here to a4 and then f6 castle on
the King side Bishop e7 and then pawn to
d3 so this is the opening that we saw in
game two firms
karyakin game for Game eleven and Game
one in this tiebreaker that we're not
going over right now played the exact
same thing so his preparation is very
very focused on this opening that's what
he feels comfortable with so that's what
we are going with pawn here to b5 Bishop
back to b3 all these moves are identical
to what we've seen so far in the
tournament pawn to d6 pawn a3 castle on
the kingside at Knight to c3 and then
Knight to a5 and this has really been
the the key difference as far as how
magnus carlsen has changed up his play
before we've seen Knight to a5 that was
kind of in that game number two then we
saw Bishop to e6 a little bit later in
game 1 of the tiebreaker we actually
solve the knight coming back here to b8
which was interesting but just preparing
for the pawn to push forward here to c5
but continues with the Knight to a5
attacking at the bishop here on b3
vision comes back to a tube and then
Bishop to e6 now in the previous game as
we saw this exact same position from
right here it was kind of pawn to d4
saying hey I know you're going to take
my bishop so I'm going to go ahead and
start to attack the sin of the board so
cardiac and decides ok I've done my
preparation I didn't like how that ended
up so I'm going to change things up and
play pawn to b4 attacking your knight
magnus carlsen that brings his knight
back here to c6 and then Knight to d5 so
all of a sudden we have a different game
here and with less time on the clock
it'll be interesting to see who kind of
comes out of this preparation ahead
Knight here it's a d4 nice little
outpost move a Knight to g5 just being
pretty proactive from cardiac in Bishop
takes on d5 and then the pawn recaptures
Knight back here to d7 so all of a
sudden cardiac can has the double bishop
hair all of a sudden we see double pawns
in the D file for cardiac and so I'd say
all in all pretty even and magnus
carlsen has a few options here he could
bring his knight over here to d7 push
forward with his pawn to f5 start to
attack on the Kings side he could play
more of a pawn to
you see six and then after pawn takes
here on c6 you could recapture with his
night play more defensively in my
opinion so decided to play a little bit
more aggressive and I think that that
was this kind of plan for most of you
know the end of the 12 rounds is he knew
that he could be pretty aggressive in
the rapid chess because I think he's a
stronger player overall than Sergei
karyakin so plays Knight to d7 and then
after Knight to e4 then starts to push
forward with pawn to f5 Kuryakin moves
his knight back here to d2 kind of
blocking off a some of his development
for his other pieces but really wants to
kind of maneuver this somewhere else
Ponta forests are starting to push his
advantage on the king size Magnus
Carlsen pawn up here to c3 force to the
knight back nine back here to f4 and
then Knights here to e4 this is a really
good square for cardiac ins night since
Magnus Carlsen doesn't have his
LightSquared bishop he essentially is
going to need to trade off and they can
no longer have double pawn structure on
the D file so all now really good square
for this night here on e4 Queen here to
e8 just getting ready to get over to the
King side of the board if he wants to
pawn up here to b3 I really don't like
pawn to b3 I was looking to push forward
so he doesn't have you know his bishop
kind of in the way of this rook to
protect it but I think Magnus Carlsen is
putting enough pressure on the King side
of the board
he should really try to get some of his
material involved into the King side to
kind of protect the house over here and
then if he wants to push on the Queen
side he can do that maybe try to open up
the eighth I'll get his rooks involved
but even Queen to g4 sounds good I think
you need some of that big material and
the Queen can't be forced off by
LightSquared bishop site I think that's
kind of play a preferred but Bishop to
b3 Queen here to g6 upon to f3 this I
think also is somewhat questionable I
think this blocks off getting his pieces
into the game he's not going to get his
dark squared Bishop he's not going to
move over here his queen is now kind of
blocked off that does open up the door
for the dark square Bishop which Magnus
Carlsen has to attack this King King can
always come here to h1 that's fine but
starting to
add pressure on the kingside and cardiac
and is going to say I'm going to block
this off try to hold down the fort with
what I have and then start to attack on
the queenside
so Bishop down here to h4 and then pawn
to a4 so as we said before karyakin
can't do too much else so decides let's
go ahead and attack over here a nine
here to f6 Queen here to e2 and then we
start to see some exchange on the Queen
side of the board pottery captures a
bishop here to d2 half the bishop takes
on on c3 I think this is going to be OK
for a circular karyakin comes out with a
double bishop pair all he really needs
to do is control this a file get a rook
behind enemy lines he does have this
backward pawn here on this c7 square if
you can start to attack this really
control the seventh rank
I think Kuryakin is going to have a
pretty good game man Descalso needs to
make a choice continue to try to attack
on the Kings side of the board he may
need to get another pawn involved or at
least a rook involved into the game to
really break through or he needs to
focus his energy try to get an outpost
here on d4 put more pressure even here
on e3 would be good start to put
pressure on some of the critical squares
on the Queen side and see if he can in
fact take over on the Queen side of the
board Knight here to 83 so decides
that's the outpost that he wants to go
with
I work over here to c1 we just see an
exchange on board and then Queen here
too he ate so magnus carlsen looking
like he's kind of abandoning the king
side the board getting his queen over
here starting to attack on the Queen
side first attacking this pawn on b5
pretty easy to defend with Bishop to c4
but he wants his opponent to be in
defense mode he doesn't want these
bishops to be very active he wants them
to be defending King here to h8 doesn't
want some sort of weird exchange where
the pawn comes off and then the bishops
attacking it with with the gain and
tempo Knight takes bishop recaptures
rook up here to a 3 and then pawn to e4
just opening up the door a little bit
for this dark square Bishop to get
involved into the game the bishop
captures rook takes over here on c3 and
then Queen down here to e5 also nice
little square for this Queen and center
the board we always talk about outpost
with minor pieces typically Knight
sometimes bishops but Queens can be
pretty powerful as well
the LightSquared bishop is not going to
be able to ever attack this this rook
really is never going to be able to put
pressure on this you know the Queen
could try to have a defender and then
attack this but it just gets somewhat
awkward so all in all this Queen can get
involved into the game if he wants to
easily quick move over to the Queen side
of the board get behind enemy lines so
cardiac and I would say it's kind of a
tough spot now it has to play somewhat
defensively especially with this a very
active night on this III outpost with
his LightSquared Bishop not doing too
much all manage Carson really needs to
do is start to get his rook involved
into the game he can have a pretty
strong attack on board karyakin moves
rook down here to see one we're gonna be
here to a8 I just I wasn't getting that
rook involvement to the game pawn to h3
just allowing his king a little safety
net if he needs to move same thing with
pawn to h6 both sides recognized it at
any time there could be a queen or rook
getting into this back rank wants to
make sure nothing crazy happens Queen
here to a d4 centralizing a little bit
more Queen down here to e1 completely in
a defense mode right now Queen to be to
starting to put pressure you can see
specifically on the square on due to
threatening mate and one right here
Bishop maps to come back to f1 exactly
what Magnus Carlsen is looking for
playing straight defense from white rook
down here to a 2 and then kind of a
fatal error by cardiac in
he looks at this and decides to play
work up here to c7 capture material
kudos to white for capture material
unfortunately he loses the game after
rook here to a-1 this particular spot
karyakin was forced to resign he's just
going to it doesn't really matter what
he tries to do you know that obvious if
he gets his Queen out of the way he's
going to lose his Queen he really just
need to take care of a one but then he's
just going to lose that if he tries
something you know Queen to h4 because
it dies here on f2 or g3 then all of a
sudden Knight to f2 rf1 check kind of
forcing the king can't come here doesn't
matter where it kind of comes to then
all of a sudden the knight comes back
this is all going to lose Queen to g2
that's going to be made doesn't matter
if the rook comes back down it's still
going to fall because the Queen's
protecting the square here on c1 so all
in all Kuryakin very quickly realized he
had made a huge blunder and loses this
one so he has a tough task going into
game number four he's playing the black
pieces against Magnus Carlsen who was
now up a game Magnus Carlsen if he can
draw or win game number four then he
will be the champion so let's go ahead
and get into game number four Magnus
Carlsen playing the white pieces all he
needs is a tie victory would also
suffice to be the world champion and win
it on his birthday
Sergey karyakin does need a victory to
get on to the blitz portion and tie
things up of Magnus Carlsen so let's go
ahead and get started pawn to e4 Magnus
Carlsen kind of what we expected pawn to
c5 so the Sicilian defense part of the
sharpest line to actually have some sort
of chance from black that we'd see
actually more of the Sicilian offense or
just so many variations that both sides
could have prepared for but we didn't we
saw mostly just pawn to e5 it seemed
like both sides really prepared for that
Knight to f3 pawn to d6
and then after exchanging the cert of
the board which we typically see from
the Sicilian defense we see pawn to f3
not a variation we see very often it's
the prince variation still allowing
himself to play pawn to c4 but it does
kind of expose his King a little bit
usually going to be castling on the
Kings side when you're playing the
Sicilian defense don't want to open up
the door castle on the Queen side to
have all this pressure from your
opponent's opening up you know semi open
file on the C file for the rook to come
down and attack so although this is a
pretty aggressive opening I think for
Magnus crossing he because he could just
play extremely passive try to change off
material super quickly and get a draw up
but it decides okay let's go out with a
bang here so after f3 we see pawn to e5
forcing the knight to come back here
Bishop to f7 re7
and then pop up here to c4 he has lots
of different options here I could have
played Knight to c3 just development
that's that's pretty common
Bishop to b5 check Bishop to E
see for putting pressure on these light
squares also makes a lot of sense but
decided to go with the pawn here to see
for pawn to a5 really expected and
immediately pawn to a4 just because they
don't have much time so any of these
obvious moves you just kind of expect
madness cotton played Bishop to e3 so if
you're watching along and it was a
playing the what is this person going to
play which if you're playing a very long
game and someone can be very difficult
unless you're using computer assistance
to figure out where they're going to go
but if you just look at on the board and
try to put your shoes in you know magnus
carlsen spot it's it can be very
difficult but over a blitz game
sometimes they play over the board they
don't really like long calculations
because if there's ever some sort of air
it kind of goes badly for them and so
they just kind of play the obvious move
so kind of just expected pawn to a4
madness Carlsen
looks like he's prepared this variation
because he played Bishop to e3 without
really thinking too much pawn to a4 for
tonight Knight comes back here to see
one it's a fairly interesting castle on
the kingside that up here to c3 Queen
down here to a5 so on the tip move
Sergei karyakin decides to go at his
queen involvement to the game and this
was kind of what I was hoping to see
from Sergei throughout the tournament
being somewhat aggressive trying to put
magnus carlsen in some tough spots even
with the black pieces hadn't really done
that too much but all of a sudden in
rapid chess which makes sense is getting
his queen involved very early on to the
action couldn't appear to d2 stopping
that pin so he can move his knight if he
wants to Knight to a6 could have brought
it here to c6 probably the more common
move 96 Knight down here to d4 nice
little outpost but decides to bring it
first to a6 bring here to c5 eventually
could then bring it to a c6 start to
attack on the King side of the board so
kind of has some options there Bishop d2
getting rates castle on the kingside a
knight to a c5 castle and then Bishop to
a d7 so completing development for the
most part magnus carlsen is complete
development he's moved his knight enough
to to kind of count that as complete
development rook here to abbey 1 just
protecting this pawn a little bit if it
wants to
shup a little bit on board rook over
here to a c8 so does have the semi open
file here magnus carlsen SME open file
on this d file so he eventually will
want to bring our work over here to d1
put a lot of pressure on the d file but
Sergei cardiac and says okay I'm going
to go and bring my rook over here to
start to add pressure on this C file
Magnus continues with pawn up here to b4
and then the pawns kind of forced to
take and this is actually legal move on
pissant once the pawn comes up here next
to the pond just have one move to go
ahead and take that AG identity like
this this does force after the pawn
takes kind of the Queen to come back
here you don't want the pond to come up
and now force one of these pieces to go
by the wayside but instead of the Queen
going back I almost wish you were to
play Knight to e6 still keeping the
Queen involved into the action but
decided that the Queen wasn't doing what
he wanted to right now so brought it
back here to a d8 night here to d3 just
going to get more involvement to the
center of the board
Knight back here e6 night to be for just
both sides positioning a little bit
Bishop to c6 and then work over here to
d1 and this is kind of that obvious move
he did have the option I think if he had
more time to calculate calculate he may
have played Knight to d5 after the
exchange on board Bishop takes pawn
recaptures night down here to d4 after
the exchange we see the queen up here I
think why it's going to be in a much
better position in this particular spot
is up a pawn controlling the center of
the board I think it's going to be good
but too too long the calculation I think
he played the obvious and still very
good move rook over here to d1
controlling this semi opened file a pawn
to h5 Bishop down here to F 1 upon 2 H 4
just pushing a little bit Queen over
here to f2 just protecting that a little
bit Knight to d7 opening up the door for
the bishop and the Queen to both protect
this pawn and then pawn to g3 I thought
g3 was somewhat interesting on board not
really worried about protecting the King
side the board right now Sergey karyakin
has the option to kind of blow this up
pawn takes you know
recaptures you can still protect it but
it's a little bit exposed for for my
liking in a rapid game I know in the
city okay yeah can can start to point a
lot of his material on the Kings side of
the board it's probably easier in this
spot instead of playing pawn to g3 just
and that up here to c6 start to exchange
material on board all Magnus Carlsen
really needs is a draw
so my back here to d7 and then pawn up
to g3 I say for the most part Sergey ke
Atkins done a good job of keeping
material on board putting some somewhat
interesting positions Pai necessarily
have an advantage but at least he's
giving himself a shot not really trying
to exchange material too much off the
board so later on Magnus Carlsen easily
starts running out of time can make a
mistake in this game
rook down to a3 starting to attack on
the Queen side that board a Bishop to h3
we're coming to a 8:00 at night down
here see to both sides just maneuvering
a little bit on the board we do see
Knight coming back here to see two
eventually we see pawn to be six so
pushing a little bit a rook to d2
protecting Queen c7 Rick over here d1 so
starting to add more pressure on this
central file the D file Bishop to f8
both sides not really doing too much I
thought it was interesting the bishop
move to f8 losing the protection of the
pawn here on h4 because then after you
know the knight comes down here to f4
after the bishop takes then it gets kind
of offer awkward Queen to d7 that appear
to be for ideally Sergey karyakin would
like to play Bishop to e7 so start to
attack you know this pawn right here get
his queen involved to kind of protect it
from you know this Queen as well but he
just kind of loses too much time here
Knight takes on c6 after the Queen takes
Knight up here to d5 attacking the
bishop after the bishop moves and all of
a sudden the knight can come over here
take material on f4 blacks just down too
much material so he kind of looked at it
and recognized correctly that after the
night came up here excuse me to b4 he
recognized hey something's going on even
if he didn't have to
to calculate everything he probably
realized it was going to lose too much
time to play Bishop to e7 start to
attack this pawn he said hey I'll give
it up I need to start to understand
what's going on the Queen sided board
played rook here to a3 now the knight
takes on c6 Knight recaptures that
appear to be five so this is nice little
outpost on the light square dark square
bishop not going to really be able to
chase this off the board attacking the
rook right here rook is forced to move
takes here on b3 comes back to d4
attacking the Queen
but then he decides okay we're going to
go and have an exchange on board
attacking your Queen and your rook I'm
going to go ahead and take your rook so
you get karyakin says I have to try
something so I'm gonna have a pawn
advantage I'm gonna have a passed pawn
on the B file and I'm going to give up
that rook this is a very difficult in
game all things considered they had tons
of time Magnus Carlsen wins this pretty
much 95 times out of a hundred just
because two rooks against just rook
Bishop an extra pawn not really doing
too much for him but sometimes you got
to go all out to try to just add
pressure and see if your opponent makes
mistakes so after the the Queen takes we
do have the double rook first the rook
and the bishop in game Queen area to e2
Bishop e7 attacking this pawn and then
Queen up to e6
does get a little bit tricky if he were
decide to come down here and take on h4
just because he starts to give up
material in the center of the board
which he doesn't really want to do on
board
Kuryakin continues Queen to e6 pawn h5
pushing it on the King side root down
here a3 rook up here to d3 says hey if
you want to exchange equal material
that's going to be completely fine with
me Kuryakin besides that's not the path
he wants to go down Magnus Carlsen they
kind of danced around a little bit
karyakin decides okay we can't have a
drawl so it decides to bring this rook
back here to a7 rook up here d5 rook
over here to c7 Queen down here d2 Queen
f6 and then rook to f5 continuing to put
pressure he recognizes that he can't get
too carried away he can't just start
taking rook to d6 hoping that his
opponent's going to start exchanging
here
because he always has an exposed King so
Queen down to g5 check you can see the
the King move Bishop takes it the Queen
takes in all of a sudden Queen to h5 and
then we're kind of equal in material
except there is kind of this extra pawn
that's going to fall so all things
considered this is just not going to be
exactly what Magnus Carlsen looking
forward since he just has better
material on board so instead decides to
go ahead and add pressure with rook over
here to f5 Queen down here h4 rook to c1
says hey let let's go ahead and exchange
onboard karyakin trying everything he
can he's slowly dwindling in material
rook over here to a7 Queen to f4 says
let's exchange Queens off board there is
a check so King down here to h1 Queen
down here to f2 and this is somewhat all
she wrote a rook to c8 King to h7 and
then there's a nice little deflection
move with Queen to h6 and there's no way
to stop this and so in this particular
spot he resigned if he were to take with
his king then all of a sudden that's
going to lose to just the rook over here
h8 and if for some reason he decided to
take with this pawn I think just play
rook up here to f7 checkmate as well so
Kuryakin resigns Magnus Carlsen is the
world champion yet again ends up winning
Game three with the black pieces and
Game four with the white pieces as well
so was was kind of glad the Magna
Carlsen tried to play somewhat
aggressive I think he played a pretty
interesting opening gave himself some
some solid chances I think he was more
prepared for that than circularity yakun
so all in all congratulations to the
champion this does make sense why he
ended up playing so draw in game 12 he
just felt really confident in his his
speed chess so all-in-all a fantastic
tournament we caught some some extra
games in all in all 14 games so
hopefully you enjoy the coverage and
until next time thanks for watching
appreciate the support of the channel
see you guys then